I'm dr. crispy I'm a reader and
cognitive psychology at the University
of Huddersfield I've always had an
interest and how people deceive others
for example if I were lying to you right
now how would you know would you look at
my eyes
at my body language would you look me
off online I'm Chris streets I'm a
reader in psychology at the University
of Huddersfield if we want to detect
deception we need to stop looking for
those visual behaviors that we think
related deception like eye contact or
fidgeting instead we need to start
thinking about the pieces of information
we can find in the world that match or
mismatch with the statement being
offered
[Music]
if you want to be able to accurately
detect somebody some of these lines or
tools what you need to do is you need to
listen to what they're saying and the
way that they say it not how they're
acting think about when you are talking
to somebody you meet them for the first
time now any good poker player will tell
you that it is very easy to control your
face therefore its facial cues really
aren't good cues of whether or not
somebody is lying or telling the truth
what you should be doing is you should
be listening to what people say the
verbal cues and the way in which they
say it the vocal cares a lie teller
because they're trying to think very
hard they will use probably the same
word over and over again over a very
short period of time
[Music]
there's some general research that
suggests we are about 54 percent
accurate when it comes to detecting lies
and tools and as I always say if that's
the case you might as well flip a coin
you'll be just as accurate there are
some people who think they are lie
detection wizards that they can read
subtle clues that we give off the
research suggests that this isn't the
case that there aren't lie detection
experts Liars just don't give themselves
away in any obvious fashion there aren't
good clues to deception we don't avoid
eye contact we don't scratch our face
when we lying or telling the truth these
just aren't reliable indicators and so
expert or not we have no good
information on which to make that
decision we have this idea that if
somebody is lying to us they can't keep
our eye contact
now of course Liars know this and what
they will do is they will keep your eye
contact ever so slightly longer than
normal just enough to make you feel
uncomfortable
number two misconception tends to be
when people lie they they move about a
lot they they kind of get very nervous
in fact the opposite is true when we lie
we have to think really hard so imagine
you've got a limited amount of energy
you will channel all of that energy into
telling a lie and as a consequence you
will become ever so slightly Stiller
than you normally are a third
misconception is the idea that if we
look up to the Y or we look up to the
left it determines the type of lie or
truth that we are telling a recent piece
of research has in fact debunked the
idea that looking up that way or looking
up that way is a good way to detect
deception it's not
my top tip for accurately determining
whether somebody is lying or telling the
truth is using something that we call
the honest baseline now the honest
baseline is understanding how people act
and speak when they're not stressed and
when they're being truthful so when we
ask them a question now if we find a
pretty even match between the way they
normally act and the way that they're
acting now we will be fairly happy that
they're probably telling us the truth if
we find a mismatch it might indicate
that there is something going on here
that we need to follow up with in a bit
more detail allied theory or the
adaptive lie detector Theory argues that
when we tried to decide if someone's
lying or telling the truth what we're
doing is actually quite functional and
informed with our past experience and
with the information available in the
world for instance if I claimed to have
gone to France last week and I have a
selfie of me in France that's a great
piece of information that I was actually
there are often we don't have that sort
of information
so what do we do allied theory claims
that we rather than simply guess rely on
our past experience of the world to make
an informed judgment people tend to be
truth biased they tend to believe people
are telling the truth and that may be
something we want to get rid of best
thing to do is just try to keep an open
mind and engage with the situation in a
skeptical manner I'm dr. Chris Street I
know do I have to say exactly how you've
done it or can I just kind of see it how
it comes oh yeah I'm dr. Chris feet I'm
a reader in cognitive psychology at the
University of Huddersfield I'm like
moving my hands here you can't see
[Laughter]
thanks for watching don't forget to
subscribe and click the bail to receive
notifications for new videos see you
again soon